attention c'est parti top on va démarrer
par à
benjamin castaldi tu es nul à saint
germain castanier avant qu'on démarre le
jeu et je vous posais la question avant
que je vous pose la question je propose
déjà est ce que vous voulez switcher
votre plateau avec celui de quelqu'un
n'ont actuellement pas parce que ça
dépend des
passagers ou la promesse qu'ils ont
faite c'est chacun notre chance c'est la
padawan on est ce que vous faites des
fichiers comme ces moules pour étirer au
nom c'est bien non vous citiez avec
matthieu delormeau
voiture
[Applaudissements]
à la mer c'est
pourquoi à pois pro vous avez
vous êtes droit mais peut-être on serait
peut-être que vous avez gagné au change
pas non non la wii aussi je ne crois pas
parce que j'ai des images qu'on a
non mais nancy merci non gelb à salir
son nom patrice attard vous savez
benjamin castaldi castaldi castaldo oui
on me dit tout je vois que voilà on
balance oui benjamin castaldi attention
question avait nagé intérêt bien répondu
commissions compteront huit secondes
pour répondre citer trois trucs que tu
aimes bien démonter
les puzzles les lego marc farry la
plomberie
ont démontré un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on démonte pas puzzle démonta puzzle
ouais ouais bah pour l'orangé ou le
démon et non mais monte à pneus
française peut-être chez toi mais je
sais pas à lesquin
[Applaudissements]
mais là-bas but il n'a pas bu chez nous
ça va bien très dangereux ça
[Rires]
les chéris ce que je propose c'est étant
donné que magenta castelli a triché je
propose qu'on fasse une spéciale baraka
je vais mal
tsonga lui attend l'aval du 10 au 12
décembre
non mais je n'essaie l'époque c'était
mal à définir en scène des mineurs et
oui c'est vrai ça tourne on a besoin de
place à l'abri mais c'est mourir
attention gaza
bon je sais vraiment plus en plus
d'événements vous avez énormément dray
par trois techi donne 3 technique de
l'as pour larguer ta meuf ou ton mec au
tabac alors je ne t'aime plus on te
lâche cela à comprendre évaluer
[Applaudissements]
vers 2 heures
du palais baghdadi attention et tu vois
rien chaque fois tu sais ce qu'est mon
attention ces magasins sont ouverts
aussi mal
castaldi mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya 98
secondes je suis mourir là je vous le
dis je
attention khatami cité trois choses à ne
jamais dire lors d'un premier rendez
vous amoureux
je t'aime je veux faire l'amour et de me
jeter un beau cul
je passe à bien vous entendre
bientôt question imagine trois choses
que tu ferais si tu étais invisible
j'irai dans la loge de delphine gérer
dans la douche de delphine déjeuner dans
le lit de détails
et la belle fille de ma réponse si
j'étais à mille il me bat mais
[Rires]
est il est une jalousie envers del ferro
il avait vu ta cervelle personnes ont
bien rigolé ouais ouais parler elle
parle avec moi talent plus vraiment
parler de l'émission sur les mariages il
était ivre de rage avec oman et
fredonner prodware vient pour écouter
pas ma session des mines est elle ou de
calais gaga n'a pas touché
juste mais attendez mais alors là
vraiment des bêtises ah bon l'amour
l'amour il peut exister vraiment la
terre est si clairement
un
platonique oui alors je peux faire le
nid que plateau
[Applaudissements]
mais non non non c'est pas l'amour
platonique c'est un amoureux on espère
c'est l'amour d'attentes exactement
c'est comme ça c'est le saisir en
attente
exactement c'est un des meilleurs
moments
avec un talent inattendu des années et
des années les préliminaires mais
j'essaie non
c'est pas possible non mais c'est une
forme de protéine est fermé
[Musique]
c'est les prémices
des bêtises qu'est ce qui différencie
l'amitié de l'amour le sexe sexe aux
bahamas et guillaume mais alors pas du
rhume et ça n'a rien à voir des amis
demain on couche ensemble
rouge à mi session concert plus ensemble
et on sera plein qui c'est sûr mais ça
n'arrivera jamais bien entendu mais
juste dire ou genton et comment elle
comprend rien alors c'est à dire que tu
sais quand tu veux tu as envie mais
l'entente a envie d'avoir des personnes
disposaient tous les jours à ceux dits
oui il en train de boire j'ai vu encore
tout à l'heure et regardez j'ai vu sur
google il a tapé moyenne d'âge pour les
sommes moyennes de d'espérance de vie
pour les hommes
6 6 il 6 il a tapé ça pour voir combien
de temps ils allaient attendre
ces prêts il fait rapport à l'amoureuse
d'alpine je l'avais vu c'est le dernier
truc qui n'a pas besoin gueule c'est
moyenne d'espérance de vie pour un homme
en france voilà et il a vu qu'il avait
entendu en 25 ans entendre voilà je suis
très ému et delphine et j'ai assisté à
une scène déplorable tout à l'heure on
en parlera à la maison au fond
c'est quoi la scène
découvrez un peu trop proche mais dans
des boulots
non ma fille n'a pas lui parler comme
les doubiens enfin c'est maladif un
salaire ou six noms mais obsessionnelle
non mais vraiment je crois que même ces
attaques lâches attaques et que vous
avez vraiment aller au jour tout vos
questions c'est plus à vous n'avez gagné
ça tient attention gilles verdez citer
trois trucs à répondre sur le corps de
son partenaire au du chocolat du miel et
un petit jus de fraise
vous buvez pas ce que vous dégoûter tout
bon
c'est vrai non mais vraiment eu non mais
vraiment vraiment
[Applaudissements]
doit il en fait toujours trop sans
rigoler pourquoi maintenant il est mal
assurée tu pourras pas tu me salis par
les effets secondaires
la boule agit là dedans aussi
non j attention j j vous êtes vous êtes
sauvés donnez lui un petit peu d'eau
j'ai pas ou du pain ont même une pizza
mais c'est pas vrai dit transpire mais
attention delphine
gt3 choses sur lesquelles les femmes
demandent souvent n'ont souvent elles
mentent sur leurs poitrines elles
mentent sur leur poids et sous l'orage
à l'épreuve ou chefs bien sûr manger
notamment ont été plus loin
il à arrêter complètement attention vous
savez si j'ai lu ça sur you ce matin
taureaux quand 70 qu'on comprend pas ce
problème vous avez un énorme problème
d'élocution j'ai lu ça c'est ma maison
mais je vous dit vous êtes vous êtes
vous n'êtes qu'à sa guise et c'est vrai
le pire devait surveiller il pas il fait
des phrases au
dalo d'ailleurs il ya lucho
déconner les deux talents
et alors
talonné tendance les phrases normalement
il fait d'une accélération j'ai vu un
truc que ce week end et ne jamais s'en
mêler qu'est ce qui se passe est lui sur
yahoo ce week-end deux pour cent des
femmes simulent l'orgasme en coupe pas
dire sur quoi
c'est énorme comme ça en tout cas là et
on sait qu'elle est née vous après une
fac a été interrogé c'est incroyable non
mais ça c'est fait bah oui qu'est sa
machine ça va ça va ça va
isabelle morini-bosc natation citer
trois maisons de coucher avec son ou sa
bosse sans ça va bon ça rtl plutôt de
charme et puis la gentillesse
pas partie
robin des
[Applaudissements]
bois bois me vois tous retourner
doucement ça va être l'occasion de
rhabiller allait aller simple évanoui à
belfort plus rien dans la bouche elle
y perd ça l'est mais c'est moins de
dégueulasse que sa folie dans
notre jeu c'est pas une raison pour
oublier ça
attention
ces trafics et son truc oui en fait on
s'en fout
tu dis de façon à
laisser malmener ont marié en sommes
avec lui lors nous sommes
trompés a cité trois tue l'amour pt au
lit alors n'a pas dit ce qu'on parlait
pas qu'elle se trompe et prénom oui se
trouve être ou non non non
[Applaudissements]
allez
il
croit que oui
bravo muet s'est il a dit si wade miami
et là isabelle un commentaire comme
d'habitude
troupes
[Rires]
séparé je ne sais pas si vous avez
remarqué chez vous m'aidez guillaume
genton bois en fait emule
la bulle est allé attention c'est parti
attention castany
castaldi
se répartit au monde 6 t3 de choses si
trois choses qui est un supporter est la
méchanceté la peau quiz
et la lâcheté
[Applaudissements]
attention et chérie on repasse à
matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] ça tombe sur vous luttez trois
endroits improbables ou mettre sa langue
dans sa bouche
[Applaudissements]
alors bon c'est bien la probable
attention gang question
attention
gilles verdez tas c'est 3 qualité de ton
voisin de gauche alors de droite
elle est stupide m'emmerde tout le temps
jours
[Applaudissements]
mais pas si c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon attention ça
à ce que lui en fait ça par palm rim
ça remonte dans le zen sapin cerpi
célèbre en chine
attention aux questions à
attention je vais te dire après
attention moi je devine we have ou trois
choses que tu cries pendant le sexe non
un an
attention pas piller
ses trois mois un tableau
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non direct
à dorer les femmes attendait alors
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit à ce sujet
pendant du riz il est
10 heures ou l'aérogare
alors je n'aurai que soient réglés alors
al anisi trop bourré et affaires et à
mieux on s'est arrêté là gardé sa la
merci des dettes on prend le donc tu vas
voir un petit peu
je t'aime ça compte aussi
avec tout le monde va retenir la dette
bientôt quoi j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup le projet d'abord aller
attention à ça continue question
voilà attention
mesdames
donne trois sauces qui sont mieux à
faire tout nu ou toute nue
nager danser et faire l'amour battant à
l'écran
[Applaudissements]
attention isabelle morini-bosc 6-3
surnom pour le pénis
l'europe la piste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et le talent et au bar du pas bien le
sol a dit
elle était à côté
là l'été avec ses potes là les temps
utile le sobre et
marne en mai c'était incroyable un coin
c'était quoi le troisième
oui mais
attention non je tire au hasard matthieu
delormeau j'arrête dit mais bernard ils
ont à m ils sont en fait ça n'a pas
d'humour cette option
là il a l'impression que c'est un petit
peu qu'on ait brisé
ce n'est pas cette hausse est partie
matthieu delormeau voilà si trois trucs
qui vaut mieux faire les yeux fermés
alors on va demander à castanet
la gauche
a les
attentions question beaucoup question
pour
ces shows pour
attention s'il vous plaît question pour
gilles verdez a63 animaux qui ressemble
à ton voisin de droite le chèvre
un serpent venimeux
baratin surface delphine c'est trois
choses que tu fais systématiquement
avant de te coucher ben je fais pipi
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle n'a jamais piqué au jeu je bois
de l'eau et je mets mon pyjama tarente
ça rentre ça balance et
d'après ce qu'on a entendu tout
[Applaudissements]
alors je continue sur delphine 4,6
connais bien si trois trucs qui tombe
avec l'âge
les pectoraux les testicules
ça serait
il a quel âge grenet il a
aussi
des projets 70 non à 56 ouais il va
avoir cinq mois il va avoir 50 6 mois ça
va 56 xiam ça va c'est est estimée par
sk et de ce fait les testicules qui
descend
elle pas les sonnex maurice
calmes et 84 mais oui ça n'a rien à voir
attention
matthieu delormeau énorme trois choses
sur lesquelles tu aimes tu as soir
un fauteuil un poteau et une bille
[Applaudissements]
la ja permettre aux autres
nous et des émissions c'est n'importe
quoi dans ce non sans reconnaître cela
il faut empêcher le professeur out deux
parties
n'étaient pas fichés qu'il est dans la
partie magasin